[Musique]
madame je vous écris car je suis une
jeune femme de 28 ans qui n'a jamais vu
paris j'habite avec mon mari et nos deux
enfants à baden un petit bourg en
bordure du golfe du morbihan à paris
j'aimerais faire les grands magasins à
tour eiffel visiter les musées voir la
scène et ses péniches connaître paris et
ses spectacles me promener dans le métro
enfin voir paris bouge et connaître les
parisiens et leurs habitudes
bonjour quel effet ça vous fait d'être
arrivé là à parler encore du mal à y
croire et c'est un peu triste on se
trouve que les maisons sont prises
fait de ne pas être perdu
on est venus des quatre coins de france
paris sera pour elle l'occasion de se
rencontrer de se parler
mais on rentre français
vois ça beaucoup colorés vous voyez même
moi je vous et
la chaleur aussi bien toi il ya beaucoup
de mots
ils sont tous là
ban a ajouté nous sommes arrivés
vous venez d'arriver
dans paris
oh non
bonus-tracks voulais voir de beaux on
une
rencontre entre la bretonne et
l'alsacienne rencontre aussi avec madame
rebecq la toulonnaise au fil des pages
de son petit carnet qui sont des
souvenirs qu'elle accumule
enfin la plus jeune dominés d'arrivée
quelle impression beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de bruit et des gens qui pour
proust a un vrai talent et vers 15
heures ce matin vers 7h45 l'hôtesse
m'attendais
après on a fait les grands magasins td
des objets que de les acheter
auraparavant
chinois un éventail chinois grâce à
un à prendre j'ai acheté une petite
boule avec le tour et fer de lance à
soutenir ma mère ont maintenant les sens
et pour moi c'est des bus garés à
l'intérieur
c'est marrant de morlaàs et la tour
saint jacques ouais c'est le centre de
paris
tout voir en deux jours dans une grande
balade trop rapide elle contempleront ce
que paris réserve aux touristes ces
monuments les plus célèbres
[Musique]
mais pressé bousculé sans vrai regard
critique ni curiosité historique
elles ne pourront que constater que la
réalité correspond bien aux photos des
cartes postales les boucles touristes
n'avaient pas
c'est ça la demeure de monsieur giscard
d'estaing c'est l'élysée liégeois
impressionnant
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que ce
qui se passe ici vous concernant
on va inviter l'un à noro n'ont pas
d'histoire
ne m'a pas gardé comme ça de toute façon
moi je ne
vois là
c'est pas mal ça nous plaît on
remonte et revu
[Musique]
et a fait la carte de la maison de la
radio parce que nous n'avons comme
épreuve dans une wii et
la façade
de l'hôtel des invalides et ceci c'est
l'église saint germain des prés comme ça
je les ai pas vus non nous n'avons pas
pu le voir ou non pas oui oui aux deux
bouts c'est court mais c'est drôle quand
même
mais en plus d'un paris pour touristes
il leur restait à découvrir l'essentiel
au delà des cartes postales immuable la
ville vit par elle même et par ses
habitants réseau vital pour paris le
métro impose son rythme de pulsations
souterraines il fallait 10 décembre
dominique ça va être la première fois
vous descendez enlever trop
j'imagine comment vous appelez c'est
fait
super c'est une maladie
vous paraît comment là
j'allume mon livre comme un sport
non
mais pas l'odeur
[Musique]
c'est surprenant parce que chez nous ne
se fait pas dix ans parce qu'on a peur
de l'opinion des voisins dans le métro
ou ailleurs de toute façon quand on
s'aime
les impressions les mecs en son sein
beaucoup plus bas
le grand chelem peut maintenant
tout cas il fait vraiment chaud dedans
bouillon
les gars me
jusqu'à présent
bon vespa donnez nous la baille
n'ayant jamais au grand jamais les
honneurs des guides touristiques
il fallait leur faire connaître les
quartiers populaires quartier où
subsistent encore des aspects chaleureux
vivant pittoresque et quart
[Musique]
han
oh
vous
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais devant ces quartiers qui
disparaissent sous les coups de boutoir
de la promotion immobilière
elles n'auront pas toujours les mêmes
regrets que les parisiens qui voit se
transformer pour radicalement leur
capital
qu'est ce qui vous a frappé
été donnée par un bon
il va réussir au bâtiment
oui
oui mais c'est surtout
des bals bord assez positif
ces taux ont démoli
de molly tout dans cette partie
sa mère d'eurosport c'est dommage de
démolir de vie on verra bien gardé
quelques semaines
rires ce serait dommage
faux
est ce que vous auriez préféré avoir ici
non se trouve le topo des bâtiments
ballack avec cetto
oh
imaginez pas sauf si grave dimanche
un parc dans le trou des halles c'est le
voeu d'une provinciale qui n'imagine pas
qu'on puisse vivre sans arbres ni fleurs
[Musique]
on
bon
[Musique]
oh
oui j'attends de formidable dans ce coin
comme paris aurait pu réussir à garder
dans de verdure comme d'arbres par tous
comme joli coin vous avez été surprise
qu'on est arrivé là ah oui ceci fait
vous avez déjà entendu parler du plan
des buttes chaumont n'ont pas dit non tu
ne savais même pas ce que c'était que
les biches moi je vais m'arrêter là
[Musique]
oh
il trouvait qu'il y assez d'espacés
verts à paris il n'a jamais rechigné
finit-il mais en fait c'est magnifique
de trouver celui là surtout lassé
il ya tellement de diversité d'arbres
jardin du luxembourg ça vous a plu
les statuts
le gazon celles qui vous ont plu
mais ce que l'on connaît de paris en
france et ailleurs ce ne sont pas les
espaces verts mais plutôt l'existence
dans des rues aux noms célèbres de tout
un commerce de luxe et de prestige
[Musique]
et
recevoir et des bijoux de stains
à quoi sert ce n'est pas abordable
premier
étonné un peu narquois mêmes sceptiques
elles se sont attardés dans les
boutiques découvrons ainsi l'originalité
d'une certaine mode parisienne
à notre avis la part des grands
couturiers
mais dans la rue voilà certaines belles
choses il était dans la vie c'est la vie
anon
[Musique]
bon
hu
mon bizarre c'est bizarre vous qu'est ce
que vous pensez
du charme est ce que vous croyez qu'on
veut mettre des vêtements comme ça
j en doute enfin moi je les mettrai pas
personnellement si peut-être des
t-shirts mais non jeudi déjà vu souvent
des boutiques comme ça non jamais
oh
[Musique]
voyez vous pourriez vous habiller comme
la foule
je pense pas sérieusement je pense pas
maintenant tout cas paribas ça va
tricoter mais alors dans mon petit
village la trinité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
oh
et enfin la foule des parisiens la faune
des travailleurs qui toujours pressé n'a
même plus le temps de regarder sa ville
et son spectacle quotidien
[Musique]
ce spectacle permanent que les touristes
et les badauds viennent découvrir sur la
place du tertre
où dans les grand théâtre et musique
la place après la première enquête pmi
sont vivants
[Musique]
ce sont des jeunes débutants qui
redessine
vous avancer d'un pas il vous le
regardez là bas paris bon pas de panique
pas de panique
mon dieu comme elle est jolie ne riez
pas vous allez être floue bon attention
là
[Musique]
objectif paris attention nous démarrons
sur les chapeaux de roue magnifique
premier virage réussi
deuxième virage non moins réussi je vois
ma dame qui se rient ne seriez tout de
même pas trop parce que ça me gênait un
petit peu la fête c'est démarrer
aussi vous êtes de toulon
de colas m'a dit en mettant à colmar
c'est tout tout à côté on n'est pas ce
que vincent je suis breton
[Musique]
à bompas et parmi la
haye à nos gardes nous gagnent nous
garde par tous et des médias
c'est merveilleux c'est pas toi rien
dire ni mon mari le dis toujours à y
voilà il ya madame l'insee la maps et
d'adama maman c'est la première fois que
vous voyez une revue oui
on imagine mal les gens à notre époque
ne voyageant pas alors avec les voitures
et les autoroutes et les trains qui sont
rapides la capitale est vraiment très
près de la province maintenant
c'est fantastique ce mail sortes de
choses des moyens et la maladie on en
est donc voilà c'est ça il ya toujours
des raisons donc il faut comprendre si
ces personnels sont pas venus à paris
c'est qu'il ya eu des raisons et qui
doit y avoir d'autres personnes dans
l'eure cape je leur souhaite de ramener
beaucoup de passer un séjour ici de
ramener beaucoup de souvenirs qu'elles
pourront raconter à leurs marines leurs
enfants peut-être à leurs petits-enfants
et je leur souhaite surtout d'avoir si
paris leur a plus la possibilité de
revenir nous voir plus souvent
villers-cotterêts l'igname et chacun se
sent rejeté vers sa solitude paris est
pourtant une ville de rencontre
rencontre avec l'étranger l'exotisme et
dans certains quartiers réservés c'est
surtout l'occasion pour des courses non
enfin disons
rencontre avec ceux qui résistent en au
mode de vie qu'il aurait imposée
s'arrête
rencontres étonnantes donc au coin d'une
rue qui déboule de dialogue étrange
parfois s'engager
jamais vous paraît elle découvre par et
de la première fois ce matin qu'est ce
que vous avez qu'est ce que vous lui
dites
merci surtout des personnes âgées qui
aiment sûrement le voir et et vous quand
vous avez vous êtes venu à paris pour la
première fois moi je veux avoir un pied
à pied
qu'est ce qui vous plaît plus vous dans
paris le fils
revoir paris
6/1 - quartier réservé aux jeunes
espoirs six emmy
on tourne
s'il vient du vga un peu bêtement des
moyens des gens mais les milliers
mon avantage a remis la peau
on
le bois et louis dans les reins dix ans
or un taxi
il va le long de la peine
et
je me rends voici
on
devant chez eux
roulant joyeux
dans la maison de banlieue
où ma mère ma tante
les larmes aux yeux
oh mon dieu après manger
quelques originaux comme le petit prince
bonjour
c'est le petit prince qui était vivant
je n'entends commotion avec celle ci à
brax
[Musique]
marie vous avez été le test pendant ces
trois jours quelles sont vos impressions
j'étais très content de rencontrer des
personnes de tous les coins de france et
surtout je m'étais pas rendu compte que
il ya tellement de gens qui ne
connaissent pas paris et que pour eux
c'est une très très grande joie
en deux jours sans un instant de répit
elles ont parcouru la ville ce périple
était d'autant plus fatiguant que paris
était écrasée sous la chaleur
et au trocadéro devant les bassins où
chacun sait battait en toute liberté
qu'elles ont enfin trouvé un peu de
détente et de fraîcheur
chaque mois
ben
quoi
y ait de l'amour
bon
m
hu
au milieu est ravi
moi pas
hamon
oh
m
why you
et non
une pièce
hamon
pavy
[Musique]